ja er hat es tatsächlich geschafft es
ist aktuell die größte rakete der welt
gebaut von spacex dem
raumfahrtunternehmen von ihnen maske
jetzt startet sie ins all mit seinem
tesla roadster als test fach das ist
wirklich groß alle tests sind absolviert
heute abend soll es in den weltraum
gehen was jetzt noch schief gehen kann
und warum dieser staat bahnbrechend ist
jetzt in den edlen mars chroniken bei
klicks und science fiction herzlich
willkommen
ich glaube zu keinem thema haben mich so
viele kommentare und whatsapp
nachrichten erreicht alle wollen alle
news zur falcon heavy heute abend soll
sie starten eine weltpremiere
fast 45 jahre nach dem letzten flug der
bisher heute noch größten rakete der
menschheit der saturn 5 startet ein
neues monstrum eine neue ära der
raumfahrt beginnt keine rakete kann so
vielen nutzlast transportieren je nach
ort kann sie bis zu 63,8 tonnen last in
den weltraum bringen
das ist immens bei der falken ein sind
ist 22,8 also nur ein drittel
dabei ist die falcon heavy eigentlich
eine umgebaute felgen oder anders gesagt
die erste stufe der falcon heavy ist
eine umgebaute erste stufe der falken
ein wie bei der felgen sind neun merlin
1d triebwerke an bord die jeweils in
diesem fall 8 145 kilo newton start
schub leisten dazu kommen 2 booster mit
denselben spezifikationen zusammen
leisten sie unglaubliche 22,8 minuten
durch die hohe zahl an triebwerken
können sogar welche ausfallen so dass
die mission dann nicht mehr gefährdet
wäre die zweite stufe dagegen entspricht
einer etwas verlängertem zweiten stufe
der verein mit einem umgebauten berlin
einst im triebwerk mit 617 kilonewton
schub es kam insgesamt 353 sekunden
gezündet werden
der start erfolgt an einem historischen
ort von der apollo startrampe launchpad
9 30 h in cape kennedy
von hier aus starteten alle apollo flüge
inklusive der legendären apollo 11 nur
die apollo 10 die mond umrundung die ist
nichts von dieser rampe gestarteten musk
spacex hat die startrampe für 20 jahre
von der nasa geleast und die rakete
fliegt eine vollkommen irrsinnige lasst
das muss man schon sagen den weltraum
der tesla roadster familien maske höher
gehört zur ersten generation rot sah
wurde 2009 produziert seitdem wurde er
von mas gefahren und jetzt wird es eine
strecke zurücklegen
dieses auto die noch nie ein privatauto
zurücklegt hat das ist wirklich ziemlich
absolut verrückt aber noch verrückter
ist das was sie denn maskin das auto
gepackt hat an bord wird zusammen eine
puppe seien benannt nach einem song von
david bowie aus dem album
the rise and fall of ziggy stardust and
the spiders from mars dazu muss man
wissen dass david bowie auch in einem
weltraum kostüm als ziggy stardust
auftrat
er ist jetzt quasi als samen an bord der
falcon heavy dass es wirklich der
absolute wahnsinn und eine ehre finde
ich ja eine tolle geste die audio anlage
wird den song space oddity von david
bowie spielen und dem handschuhfach ist
eine ausgabe von per anhalter durch die
galaxis von douglas adams und ein
handtuch mit der aufschrift keine
parallelen zu der seltsamen fracht ich
liebe den gedanken an ein auto das
wahrscheinlich endlos durch das weltall
driftet und in ein paar millionen jahren
vielleicht von einer außerirdischen
spezies entdeckt wird
wenn die rakete nicht beim start
explodiert das meint er denn das kann ja
tatsächlich schief gehen
der roadster wird übrigens sind eine
umlaufbahn um die sonne einschwenken und
dann weiter zum mars fliegen ihnen maske
anspielung auf seine pläne den mars ball
zu besiedeln
darüber gibt es sicher bald mehr infos
von ihm wenn ihr als erstes neues zum
thema und auch zu allen anderen themen
erfahren wollt dann meldet euch hier bei
whatsapp an dann erfahrt ihr vor allen
anderen vom neuesten video garantiert
ihr könnt dort direkt in der redaktion
vom krieg zum mitmachen und themen
vorschlagen oder fragen zu videos
stellen der direkte draht zu mir einfach
hier draufklicken und natürlich nicht
das aber mit genau vergessen hier geht
es weiter mit dafür draufklicken mit
1000 raketen zum mars da geht es um
ihnen us-pläne für die besiedlung des
mars ansonsten bis dann bleibt